i'm gonna go wash my hands oh okay okay
see you soon
buddy um i'm sorry uh you
that seat is actually taken uh my
girlfriend is in the
bathroom and she should be back any
second so you cannot sit there you don't
even recognize me do you
no no i i don't i don't know you we were
in that human centipede together i said
i do not know you three years ago we
were kidnapped by the crazy german
scientist who surgically connected us
into a single human digestive chain
there were three of us i was in the
middle you were at the end the other guy
was up front
your mouth was sewn to my bottom okay
yes i remember
and after years of therapy i finally put
that behind me probably should have said
you put it behind me if you catch my
drift
i'm sorry i'm sorry you already caught
my drift i'm sorry
that's it it was right there in front of
me i'm sorry
i guess it was right there in front of
you that's it i'm sorry
how are you doing how are you there's
something else i can help you with um
hey get right in front man
this is a big nightmare hey back man
batman no
don't call me that couple squat no
oh chilly old habits die hard nice one
oh no i can't eat it the word why are
you happy to see him
come on man you know we all shared the
same experience no we didn't
he was in the front nobody in his mouth
that was true do you ever stop eating
ever only when i'm okay well but
me and you right mean you what i mean
we were in the same boat nope you two
were in the same boat
you both sit in someone's mouth i didn't
get in anyone's mouth
when do i get to anybody's mouth huh
when do i get
in somebody's mouth stephen
i no these guys i can explain this
i can explain this oh you're disgusted
you no now you're gonna leave oh yeah
that's great
oh yeah once again i'm the [ __ ]
you